gather around sci-fi fans YouTube wants
to tell you an origin story if you're
confused about how the first season of
the big-budget YouTube premium show
wrapped up and what the developments may
mean for the show to come keep watching
as we break down the twists filled
ending of the streaming services newest
hit origin starts onboard a spaceship of
the same name with a small group of
people left behind one hour after an
unexplained evacuation each passenger is
seeking a new start with a clean slate
promised by the mysterious siren
organization and their colonization
project on the distant planet via it's a
framework that justifies a lot of
distrust between the passengers
especially the first two we meet former
Yakuza members shewn and former
bodyguard Lana their relationship is
founded on skepticism but the two have
little choice but to work together
despite mutual paranoia if they become
the leaders of the surviving passengers
the end of the season focuses on their
relationship with the two forming a
tentative trust that ends in brutal
betrayal when the passengers come across
injured crew members Evelyn Rae and dr.
max Taylor they soon discover that
Taylor's possessed by an alien parasite
trying to mimic the behavior of a normal
human being
max Taylor medic
human an autopsy reveals the alien to be
a slender worm that installs itself in
the brain where can survive and
reproduce while the one attached to
tailor dies one more lives on taking up
residence in the head of a crewman who
calls himself Eric which Lee later
discovers is not his real name
after fake Eric is discovered to be
another alien host the passenger honoré
makes an attempt to blast him out of an
airlock the plan fails but Eric is still
defeated shortly after when his brain is
examined it's found that the alien
escaped thus begins a season-long
mystery which one of the passengers did
the surviving alien jumped to as origin
draws nearer to Theo with the mystery of
the alien still unresolved
the ship's AI goes into a failsafe mode
activating a security plan called
protocol 47 detecting the presence of an
alien life-form the ship begins emitting
a lethal gas moving through the ship
with the aim of killing everything on
board suddenly instead of simply waiting
out the threat the survivors are forced
to either solve the mystery or die
trying
with origin barreling toward Thea with
no easy answers in sight the passengers
stockpile oxygen tanks to try and wait
things out but then soon makes a
horrifying discovery
separate from the other passengers he
comes across two vital pieces of
information a video diary of Max
reciting a childhood memory that Lana
later presented as a roan and an audio
recording of Lana rehearsing her own
humanity I know I'm still here
as it turns out the alien never had
anything to do with the suspicious
bomber Katie the truth is indisputable
Lana is the alien but when did she
become infected in the beginning
Lana really is who she says she is but
halfway through the season she ends up
with the parasite that originally
existed in fake Eric to fill in the
blanks the final episode goes back to a
few critical moments showing new
perspectives of what really happened
while most of the characters weren't
looking when fake Eric escaped from
Audrey's attempted airlock attack at the
end of episode 4 he pled to a pool room
finding Lana hunted injured and
desperate to survive the alien attacked
her traveling between the two of them
and killing the first toast in the
process this means that our heroine
turned evil off-screen sometime between
episodes 4 & 5 ever since then we've
been watching Alana working to deceive
the others and keep its alien self alive
after taking over Lana the alien
sabotage any equipment that might have
helped test for its presence it also
killed Lee and framed Katie it's only
found out because of its one known
weakness it can't access people's
memories but in Lana's case at least
this doesn't seem so clear-cut
Lana seems to still be in there
somewhere not just bringing up old
memories but actually fighting for
control of her own body with adding foe
in mind it doesn't sound like the Lana
we knew will be gone for long if the
series gets a second season
you can bet our heroine will figure out
a way to vacuum out that alien worm
before all of this happens Rey and
Abigail make a discovery that's arguably
even more chilling than their encounters
with the aliens
not only are there terrifying monsters
in the system that mimic human beings
sirens seem to know about them
specifically Rey and Abigail discover
that Thea has a neighboring world iris
that was kept secret from both
passengers and crew based on video
footage and files they find it seems
like it may be the alien homeworld and
it's very dangerous for humans Rey
deduces that siren knew the planet was
populated by hostile aliens and sent the
origin ship toward Thea anyway the
company also prepared for possible close
encounters without telling most of the
people on board
that's why protocol 37 exists because
Saren knew there was host whole-life
near thea protocol 47 is Rea points out
is an emergency measure designed
specifically to annihilate crews
compromised by parasites but the show
also hints at the secret in more subtle
ways in the third episode rape flashback
dr. Taylor is surprised to discover that
the ship has guns on board also captain
Sanchez seems extremely certain that
cell 50 is a lost cause when it's
breached by an asteroid impact almost as
though she knew that asteroid might
carry hostile life it's information that
throws everything the crew and
passengers may have took on faith and a
serious doubt with that mind it's hard
to imagine what might be waiting on the
planet's surface paradises promised or
some terrible new threat the season ends
with an ominous message and it couldn't
be more clear of a warning don't land on
thea given what the origin passengers
know by the final episode all the lofty
promises they've been sold about thea
become questionable at best iris at
least seems completely overrun by the
same aliens the origin passengers have
been evading for a week is Thea
compromised - origin doesn't end in a
way that wraps things up conclusively it
feels like it's just getting started
what is sirens real goal on Thea and why
not the passengers know about it what's
the situation on the planet will on re
survive what about Lana and hey is that
conversation about faster-than-light
experiments space-time curves and time
travel are going to amount to anything
they like tiny time truffle machines so
in theory you could treat it moments
from your past or future one way or
another it seems the origin survivors
are far from done fighting for their
lives maybe they should just turn the
ship around and try returning to Earth
who knows the possibilities seem endless
so here's hoping we get to see what all
these origin stories are building toward
with a season two
[Music]